tables rondes ateliers formations sur la
gouvernance des communes voilà le
programme de l'édition 2016 de
l'université des mairies des yvelines
élus communaux départementaux régionaux
et parlementaires se sont retrouvés
mercredi 12 octobre pour échanger
notamment sur la situation budgétaire
des communes yvelinoise très exactement
dans les yvelines
le chiffre de des dotations aux communes
et est en 2014 de 300 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui il est de 205 millions
d'euros
les communes et les intercommunalités
ont été gelée dire les généreux
donateurs
un retour à l'équilibré critiqué ces
derniers temps sur l'augmentation de 66
% de la taxe foncière
le président du département des yvelines
tente de se justifier
tout comme la région concernant les
économies réalisées un département c'est
la filiale je le dis pour ceux qui
travaillent dans l'entreprise pour
essayer d'être pédagogique
c'est la filiale d'un grand groupe qui
s'appelle l'état et cet état fait
n'importe quoi est en faillite et donc
transfert dans la filiale que nous
sommes tous ces risques pour y est c'est
pour ça que nous sommes dans cette
situation de grande difficulté
oui on demande à tout le monde de faire
des économies mais cet argent je le
réinvestis et pourquoi je le réinvestis
parce que ce serait un drame que la
france et les communes notamment ne
puisse plus investir parce qu'on leur
coupe les budgets tant que je suis à
fond sur l'aide aux investissements et
notamment des communes le projet loi de
finances 2010 est actuellement en
discussion au parlement prévoit une
limitation de la baisse des dotations
aux collectivités locales
une mesure prise suite aux annonces du
président françois hollande en juin
dernier